it's a major escalation of u.s economic
sanctions against russia for its
invasion of ukraine on tuesday u.s
president joe biden went after president
vladimir putin's most lucrative industry
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
the decision by president biden to ban
russian energy imports into the united
states follows pressure by the u.s
congress and pleased by ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski
biden acknowledged the latest sanctions
could cause a spike in u.s gas prices
consumers are already paying on average
more than four dollars a gallon up from
2.77
just a year ago due to high inflation as
the economy recovers from the coveted
pandemic since putin began his military
buildup on ukrainian borders just since
then
the price of the gas at the pump in
america went up 75 cents
and with this action it's going to go up
further
the white house is directing the release
of some of the u.s strategic petroleum
reserves to contain prices and
compensate for lost supply but the white
house maintains high gas prices might
also encourage u.s consumers to switch
to green energy and electric vehicles
but this analyst says the united states
is nowhere near ready the biggest user
of oil in any country is transportation
and transportation depends on having
things like electric vehicles and hybrid
vehicles those vehicles represent a
relatively small part of the fleet the
fleet turns over slowly so the green
economy we're talking about years
that's why these latest u.s economic
sanctions against russia may be symbolic
designed to hurt putin financially but
mostly politically
president biden is sending his vice
president kamala harris to poland and
romania this week to reinforce support
for ukraine but also to reassure nervous
allies fearful that russia could turn
its aggression
on them next
kimberly helkin al jazeera the white
house